The key optimal substructure for
the sequence alignment problem
comes from aligning prefixes of
the sequence that we want to align.
We define c(i,j) to be the minimum cost
of a aligning the first i characters
of x with the first j characters of y.
Since x has m characters total, and
y has n characters, our overall
goal then is to compute c(m,n) and
the alignment that achieves it.
Let's consider this problem of
computing c(m,n), and in particular,
we'll consider what we do with
the last characters of each sequence.
There are three cases to consider.
First suppose that we match
the last two characters of
the sequence together like so.
Then the cost would be the minimum
cost of aligning the first
m minus 1 character to the x with
the first n minus 1 characters of y,
plus the cost associated with
matching these two characters.
Another possibility is that we leave
the last character of the x sequence
unmatched.
Then the cost would be the minimum
cost of aligning the first m
minus one characters of x,
with the first n characters of y,
plus one for leaving Xm unmatched.
In the case where we leave
Yn unmatched is analogous.
Of course c(m,n) is defined to be the
minimum cost of aligning the sequences,
so it must be the minimum of
these three possibilities.
Notice, however,
that there was nothing special about the
fact that we were using m and n here.
And the same argument applies
to all combination of i and j.
The problems are similar.
So we can replace m and
n with i and j like so.
Adding the base cases where
the cost of aligning a sequence
with the empty sequence is just
the length of the sequence.
We have a recursive formulation.
The optimal solution,
expressed in terms of optimal
solutions to similar subproblems.